hi folks yeah as you can tell from my
accent I'm from Los Angeles originally
who here climb the stairs to get up to
this room keep your hands up if you took
public transport to get to USC campus
Wow
I didn't manage that alright great I'm
gonna talk about today is server list
for day scientists and we're going to
talk about data science about halfway
through the talk for the rest of the
talk the first half is gonna feel like
DevOps and that's like necessary eating
of your greens that you have to do to
get to the good data science stuff so if
you're worried halfway through this
seems kind of weird
don't leave data science is coming this
could have been a you know ninety minute
tutorial where we do stuff interactively
and rather than do that I put all the
code on github so by all means try and
follow what I'm saying as well as you
can but you do have the luxury of
checking this stuff out after the talk
so let's get started
these are computers and I think it's
generally agreed that these things were
a bad idea
one of the great things about the cloud
is it allows you to put the hardware at
least in a sort of a notional trash can
of your mind if you like by moving to
the cloud the hardware becomes somebody
else's problem the power the air
conditioning swap makes swapping out
broken hard drives all that is someone
else's problem and the usual suspects
Amazon Microsoft Google do such a good
job of that that you can effectively
forget that the hardware exists exists
modulo that be at the start of any
project where you choose am I going to
use like a P 2x large or a t2 micro or
whatever you can pretty much forget the
hardware apart from that there are a
couple of problems with moving to the
cloud though this is one of them it
turns out to be on average a fairly
efficient way of setting fire to money
and there are exceptions and kind of one
of the themes of this talk is a way of
using the cloud inexpensively
but generally speaking this is true and
the reason it's true is in the move to
the cloud or even if you do stuff on
your own hardware you necessarily set up
long-running large services that have
Headroom that have room to grow as your
as your needs grow and what that means
is you're not running at 100%
utilization you are necessarily burning
dollars for unused CPU time
the other aspect the other thing that
remains a problem when you move to the
cloud and again this is equally true on
on-premises installations is this this
is recent footage of me configuring
maintaining and securing an operating
system this is not my job I'm not good
at it it's not something particularly I
like to do and I think most importantly
it's not how my company makes money by
me doing this so I'd love to stop doing
it I'd love to live in a world where not
only the hardware goes in of a notional
trashcan but also the operating system
that contain the technology all that
nonsense I can forget about it and focus
solely on the business logic of what I
need to do the application layer that is
the claim at least of serval it's that's
its goal so let's take a second to sort
of define one way of thinking about what
civilus is so imagine I've got an idea
for a business I've got a new unicorn
startup idea what I want to do is
provide an API that adds two numbers
together and I believe I'm gonna be the
next slack if I do this so business is
going well already I've got my first
request and then it comes and so one
wants to know what's two plus two
in a service deployment what happens is
some kind of long-lived gateway service
summons out of thin air a server that
server performs this computation and
those of you had your coffee will
already have figured out what the answer
is and then crucially this is the
defining aspect of service that server
goes out of existence it was somewhat
into existence not to perform this
service generally but just perform this
service for that single function call so
business is going really well now and
along comes another request and the same
thing happens my gateway service summons
out thin air some hardware to perform
the computation and then that piece of
hardware dies a noble death because as
though it's never existed what you'll
note here is between these two calls to
my API
I had no infrastructure and it's in that
sense that this is a service deployment
the server's are created only as and
when they're needed for those of you who
are like hardcore data scientists who
know what Bayesian nonparametric is you
know that's a terrible name because
nonparametric actually means lots of
parameter
serverless is kind of the same deal in
practice services used in situations
where we don't get to API calls over the
three minutes it took me to explain that
slight it's when we get lots of API
calls so us but the point is our
infrastructure scales up linearly with
the amount we're using it and crucially
that linear relationship again for the
data scientist the room has an intercept
of zero or very close to zero we do not
pay for our infrastructure when we're
not using it so given that we want to
forget about operating systems and
hardware and stuff this is a nice story
but clearly we'd like to pay someone
else to solve all the technical details
that enable us to work as data
scientists or operations people to work
in this way and that's where these these
folks come in so AWS lambda is perhaps
the best-known server list platform
Google Cloud has functions azure has
functions and then if you feel very
strongly about the details of your
deployment you've got someone else to
take care of the problems that come with
it for you there are open source it's
like roll your own implementations of
serverless and open fast is one of them
one of the better-known ones but
certainly not the only one throughout
this talk I'm gonna be using AWS lambda
I think it's the most mature certainly
and a lot of the tools I'm gonna be
using our targeted at it for now let's
actually do something with serverless
and this is where you might be worried
that I'm not going to talk about data
science this is a web application this
is a flask application for those of you
haven't seen flask before don't worry
about most of the details just look at
that function in the middle that
function time hopefully it's obvious
what time is doing time is returning a
string that gives the current time no
one's going to win a Turing Award for
this but we'd like to deploy it so I'm
gonna make it a flask application the
way you wire a flask application
together is you use one of these
decorators which is the line immediately
before the function definition that says
two flasks if a request comes in to your
website comm slash time give the user
the return value of that function and
obviously for like an interesting web
application that would be some HTML with
some templates and stuff like that but
yeah we're just gonna return the time so
how do we deploy this this is what a
local deployment of this application
looks like I just run Python app py and
flask very helpful he tells me at the
end the URL I can find it out which is
localhost port 5,000 and then if I visit
that URL I could do this in the browser
but just for this slide it's airing with
a curl command I get the time and
apparently I was writing this talk at
9:00 at night a couple of months ago so
that's all great but obviously I have
aspirations to close the lid on my
laptop at some point I also don't want
to deal with the security implications
of serving a web application as a
long-running service so I would like to
deploy this in the more formal sense so
let's do that
using server lists and one of the nice
things we'll see is this turns out to be
relatively cheap so how do we actually
do this deploying on a web application
on server list involves a tremendous
amount of clicking around in the AWS
console I don't recommend it what I
recommend you do instead is use a
command line tool and there are three
that I know about zapper is the one
we're going to be using in this talk
chalice is AWS is official equivalent
that only works with AWS Lanka zapper at
least in principle is agnostic about
which serverless back-end you're using
and then confusingly there is a node
option called serverless which is a not
a great name for something but is
officially it's called the civilus
framework you'll hear it called server
lists and like I say it requires to you
to use the node package manager which is
you know most of us don't have time for
that so we're going to use Zappa for
this talk the first thing to note and
I'd say this a data science conference
is you have to use virtual environments
you can't use anaconda distributions for
this you're going to have to define
locally and create locally a virtual
environment to deploy this application
so before this slide I created a virtual
environment on the second line there I'm
going to activate it and in pip install
the one dependency of this web
application which is flask and then I'm
going to run Zappa in it and that is
zappers way of gathering the information
it needs to deploy the application what
you're not seeing here off the screen is
five or six questions that I get asked
and in fact because this application is
so simple
configuring it consists of hitting Enter
six times so it's not rocket science and
you can tell it's like a nice cool tool
because there's a skier right at the
start and once it's done what you've got
written to disk is this file this is a
config
raishin file that tells his Apple how to
deploy this thing and most of this is
boilerplate the only interesting thing
here is the first configuration entry
entry app function that app app there is
telling AWS lambda or zapper and then
AWS Lander that when a request comes
into this service the Python object you
want to use to service that request is
the object app in the file app py which
was that flask application I showed you
a couple of slides ago so we've
configured things but now we actually
want to deploy it and it may not
surprise you to learn that the command
to do that is Zappa deploy and here's
all the stuff we could be clicking in
the console if we hated ourselves
there's a lot of stuff to do here
but the good news is it's all taken care
of if I were doing this live I think
this takes maybe 30 seconds I mean you
can do a Zappa update which takes less
time if you make a change to your
application and not your dependencies
but the important thing is right at the
end here there's a publicly accessible
URL and I think if any of you want to
know what the time is right now if you
type that URL in really quickly you'll
get the time or I can tell you if you
want to at the time um but the important
thing like I say is most of this stuff
it's wonderful not to have to worry
about it one thing I want to just draw a
little bit of attention to is that line
fourth line down packaging project has
zip
that's what Zappa does for us it
packages up our application and it's
dependencies in a zip file which is the
thing that gets uploaded to AWS it takes
care of that for us and the reason it's
able to infer dependencies is its
definition of dependencies is everything
it finds in the virtual environment so
don't install notebook don't install
scifi if you don't need it in these
virtual environments keep them nice and
clean because that's the thing that's
going to get uploaded to AWS and once
we've done that we can curl this URL and
get the time and apparently it was 4:30
in the morning when I was writing this
talk it wasn't really that's UT at 9:30
at night in the Pacific time zone so
that's AWS servers time zones then if
you're interested on the github this and
more code to show how you take URL
parameters how you handle time zones all
that sort of stuff or a more slightly
more complicated web application but
we're now going to move on to a second
use case that serverless is great at
which is cron jobs for those of you
don't know cron jobs are
curring tasks things that recur a set
time each day a set number of times each
month or each year or whatever this is
things like defragment my harddrive
download this URL these sorts of
bookkeeping tasks and I built a cron job
that is this Twitter bot if you go if
you follow on Twitter dwx DTLA that's
changing weather in downtown LA and it's
just a bot that tweets the weather every
morning at 7:30 and I don't actually
know what a Fahrenheit is so I added a
function to it that tells me if it's
warmer than yesterday or colder than
yesterday
that's my great innovation for 2018
there are two of these BOTS there's one
for New York City as well this is all
done by Cyril it's I pay less than a
cent a month for this to happen you know
60 times a month for the two bots the
configuration file to get zapper to
deploy this ends up being a little bit
more complicated I had to write this one
by hand a little more but I just want to
highlight two additions from the last
one we saw one the expression thing
there is essentially a crontab line if
you've used cron on a UNIX system before
this is a thing saying do it every hour
on the on the half hour and then the
second big block of environment very of
configuration there is the environment
variables that's where I can inject
application specific configuration in
this case the latitude of the place I
want the Twitter bot to post the weather
for and my you know my passwords and
things like that so that's all wonderful
and of course the reason it's wonderful
is money but I want to talk about a
couple of other reasons why if you talk
to operations people some of them really
like serverless one is we were able to
focus on business logic apart from like
using analogies like cron jobs there I
didn't really talk about unix in any way
we were able to focus mostly on business
logic additionally and we didn't really
see it because I've got two twitter bots
not a billion Twitter boss but
additionally we're getting scalability
essentially infinite scalability built
into the application the second we
deploy it and obviously were going to
pay for that if we end up with an
infinite number of users but we do at
least have the scope to grow immediately
without thinking about scaling out any
of that sort of stuff but the advantage
that interests me at least is this one
it's money and that's because we're only
paying
while it's running those grunt those
cron jobs cost me zero essentially I
believe Amazon rounds to the nearest
cent which means I think they do
actually cost me zero and then the web
application it's only gonna cost me what
I get in terms of users so if I if my
time service is successful then good for
me and it's gonna cost me a little bit
of money
um well dig into what these cost savings
mean for data science in a second but I
want you to hold them in your mind
here's an example from the operations
community of like a big big financial
savings this is the readability API if
you know Instapaper readability is a bit
like instapaper
so you take in a rich web page full of
headings and adverts and pull quotes and
media and stuff like that and you give
the URL to the readability API and it
gives you back the plain text version of
the web page to display like a reader
friendly format and then the you know
the economics of the media industry
collapses but it's a wonderful service
and they used to pay $10,000 a month to
instant to run this on ec2 instance they
migrate it to server list and now it
cost them three hundred and seventy
dollars a month so ten thousand dollars
to three hundred and seventy dollars a
month is a big big saving now it's not
all sweetness and light it's not all
good news there are a couple of problems
two of them are sort of disadvantages
that are in the nature of server lists
to the extent it's like micro services
micro services is a way of deploying a
relatively complex application and
civilus shares some of its
characteristics and one of the
criticisms you're hear of micro services
is that they tend to be complicated they
tend to have a large surface area
internally to the application and that
can make debugging tricky is just as a
practical matter the other disadvantage
of server lists I want to acknowledge at
least but it's not going to bother us
for most the rest this talk is vendor
lock-in I can't take this application if
it's a moderately complicated one and
just SCP it from AWS Lander to Google
Cloud it doesn't work like that and that
vendor lock-in can be vicious for
interestingly sized application and it's
something if you're thinking of doing
something at a reasonable scale it's a
real concern that you should consider
but the disadvantage that is more
interesting from the point of view of
the rest of this talk is this one and
this is not so much a disadvantage as
the
point the premise of server lists these
machines that are summoned out of thin
air we haven't talked much about what
they are there are real sort of logical
machines containers or something running
on AWS hardware well I I you know I like
to think I know a reasonable amount of
service and about civilus I don't know
much about these machines and that's um
a measure of the success of the
abstraction but they are machines and
they are actually quite under-resourced
machines they're not quite as
under-resourced as this picture but
there is a hard upper limit right now I
think of 1.5 gigabytes of RAM on an AWS
lamdaur instance there is a hard upper
limit that the function has to return
within 300 seconds and that was
increased to 15 minutes which is 900 900
seconds so it that limit is going up but
it's a limit nonetheless so if you've
got an interesting sized data science e
computation it takes 20 minutes rather
than 15 minutes you're out of luck for
surplice so that's a real thing to
consider so these things are under
powered machines on borrowed time and
those constants I mentioned one and a
half gig 3 minutes 3 or 5 minutes 15
minutes they're all likely to change
since I first gave this talk the 5
minute went to 15 minute limit and if
you go to Google Cloud or Azure they're
different numbers and if you roll your
own install it on your own hardware
would open for us you can choose
whatever those numbers are for your use
case but the fundamental idea that these
are machines that pop out of existence
once they've run the function is the
point of service and what that means is
it kind of restricts the kinds of
functions you write on their own these
functions have no way to remember what
happened the last time they were called
they also have no way to communicate
with other functions running at the same
time you can like I want to say I was
gonna say hack that in it's not really a
hack it's how people do it but you can
call out the databases you can have side
effects like posting to Twitter so
they're not truly pure functions in that
sense but it does change the way you
think a little bit about programming so
finally this is we're getting to the
data science bit and here's a picture of
data science we've got these machines
that have no internal state they're not
very fast either but the important thing
is potentially we've got a very very
large number of them and we can summon
them out of existent
into existence and out of existence is
that effectively instantly and only pay
for them while we're using them which
raises a really really interesting
possibility for data science use cases
so if you get one thing from this talk I
would love for you to read this paper
this is an academic paper but it's a
relatively accessible academic paper and
it introduces a tool called pi Retton
which is what we're going to talk about
in the rest of the talk is like how you
actually hands-on keyboard use pi r own
but i think this is also an interesting
piece of research and sort of a polemic
about how we can do distributed
computing when not everyone works at
Twitter and Google and Facebook and like
I say this is the paper that introduces
pi r n and pi r n is a tool that map's
functions across parameters using AWS
lamda as the computational backend so
let's first look at what I mean by map's
functions across parameters without
using AWS lambda I'm going to map
functions across parameters on my own
laptop here so here's my function this
is square so it takes a phone number X
and it returns its square I would like
to map that across some parameters in
this case the number 0 to 5 inclusive
and the usual Python way of doing that
is with a list comprehension so this is
going to give me 0 squared 1 squared 2
squared and so these sort of haskell
nerd way of doing the same thing is with
the map function the map function has at
Python 3 does not directly give you back
the answer it gives you this map object
which you saw has the possibility of
giving you the answer if you call list
on it it's a generator there this is
complete sidebar to the rest of the talk
but the reason i emphasizing Python
through here is you're a PI data
conference you should all be on Python 3
now because a little library you might
have heard of called num pi is dropping
support for new versions of Python 3 in
January 2019 which I used to think was
like the Space Age but I thought to
myself dude what did I say that would be
a very aggressive timeline wouldn't
droppings again everyone leaves the talk
immediately so they're dropping support
for Python new versions of Python 2
starting in January which I used to
think was like the far future but it
turns out that's like 10 weeks away so
you should all be on Python 3 now but
ideally Python 4 apparently um so
but the point is this is how you do it
on your own machine we'd like let's say
I've got a really old laptop and I do
actually have quite an old laptop and
I'm worried about its ability to compute
these five these six calculations these
six quite numbers I'm gonna shift the
computation now to six AWS lamda
instances using PI R n so that is how
you use pirate import pirate then you
create this executor object and the
significance of the executor object is
that it has a map method that is API
compatible with pythons map map map
function so it takes a certain arguments
the function you want a map and the
parameters you want to map them across
again just like Python trees built-in
map function it doesn't give you the
answer it gives you something that will
allows you to get the answer and in
parens case it's going to give you a
list of futures objects and you can call
result on these futures objects and get
the result back and accumulate all the
results there so that's very nice
I'm not live coding now and if I were
you'd see a frankly rather alarming
amount of time it took to do this this
takes about 20 seconds just hit return
five times here and it that it takes the
time when you call the result method
when it accumulates the answers so let's
let me put my cards on the table and
show you what's what's going on here
this is a plot of how the time taken by
these six workers that do this con
computation
the workers are each a row on the plot
and then the x-axis is time and if you
can't read the scale of the x-axis the
limit the upper limit the x-axis is 20
seconds so this whole thing took 20
seconds to take the square of six
numbers which is yeah not a win
computationally but I want to break down
what's going on and then we'll talk
about some use cases where it is a big
win so what is pyrin doing to use lambda
as the back end first the blue dots
correspond to host submit and what that
means is package up your application and
upload it to AWS and in fact the place
that uploads it to it may not surprise
you is s 3 then tasks start means summon
into existence six AWS lambda Workers
which then ask this SS three bucket for
the application and additionally in this
case they install an anaconda runtime so
the people who built PI R n are very
much focused on users like you and me
who
all need the same set of like ten
libraries numpy site pi scikit-learn i
don't think there's a deep learning
library in there which is fine because
there's no GPUs on lambda but these this
sort of set of this data science
ecosystem is install so if you want to
do something different
pyro may not be for you if you feel
strongly about version numbers PI R n
may not be for you but for now in this
installing an anaconda runtime is great
because it means we don't get in a mess
with like Fortran compilers on AWS
lambda which is no fun so the
application is now on these AWS lambda
instances and and the runtime necessary
to do the calculation that's setup done
the computation is performed as tasks
done and results returned is the bit
where my client in this case the laptop
calls that result method and you can see
those results are staggered there and
that's the latency of my internet
connection that's the Grove global
interprets a lot and each one taking a
second for me to pull down so this whole
thing adds an overhead a huge overhead
like twenty seconds so don't use AWS
lambda don't use PI R n to do things
that take less than 20 seconds they have
to be inside of a sweet spot which is
now from like 20 seconds to 15 minutes
which is there's quite a lot of stuff we
do gate today that's in there and I'll
show you how to move stuff into that
domain as well for a speed up in a
second but one thing I would want to
note about PI R n don't actually do this
but this emphasizes pi r n is a drop-in
replacement for the map function
potentially if you wanted to globally
change all the maps in your application
to use PI R n inside of your own
computer you could run this at the start
just overwrite the map function and that
sort of shows off that pyrin is
compatible and also that python is like
a dangerously dynamic language where i
can rewrite the standard library at
runtime why would i do this or why
wouldn't I do this I would do this I
would benefit from PI R n if the things
being mapped the computations being
mapped are embarrassingly parallel
that's the use case that PI R n serves
so we need to define embarrassingly
parallel and this is our third and final
use case for service so what does in
what is embarrassingly parallel this is
a field of carrots we would like to
harvest these carrots
if we've got one tractor we've got
eighty carats here ten rows sorry
eight rows of ten carats and this
tractor confirm that the carrots at one
carrot per second this tractor is
clearly going to take 80 seconds to
complete this field if we are willing to
pay for a second tractor we can get this
field done in 40 seconds
and if we're willing to pay for eight
tractors we can get the whole thing done
in ten seconds we are getting a linear
speed-up as a function of the number of
tractors we've got and the reason for
that is that the tractors operate
independently they don't need to talk to
each other say can I look at your carrot
before I pick up this carrot it's a
totally independent operation that's in
contrast to let's say two people who
agree to write a book together they need
to coordinate one person needs to write
one chapter because it affects another
chapter so they need to work kind of in
series rather than in parallel
embarrassingly parallel is this kind of
extreme parallelism where no
communication is required between the
workers taking the square of six numbers
is embarrassingly parallel the naive
implementation of the algorithm to do
the square of lots of numbers you do not
need to know the square of two in order
to compute the square of three there are
actually speed ups if you do know that
but the naive version is embarrassingly
parallel so we're on we're looking for
things that are embarrassingly parallel
and in that sweet spot of taking
somewhere above 20 seconds and below 15
minutes so here's a real example of this
from my own work so but this is all
cannot about data science that you spend
most of your time preparing data and
getting data rather than training you
know recurrent neural networks and
that's you know normally my job is to
train recurrent neural networks and it's
true for me as well so I wanted to get
all the abstracts from nips nips as a
machine learning conference it was in
long beach last year and it's it's hell
on earth if you ever get a chance to go
so I recommend you run this code rather
than go so he'll get the abstracts and
if you're interested in the either the
abstracts or the code then there's a
github link there scrape batch here is
the function we're going to map across
parameters and the parameters are going
to be batches of URLs you might think
write a function just scrape one URL and
map it across a list of URLs but instead
I'm going to write a function to scrape
batches and map it across a list of
batches and the batches are like a
hundred papers long and that is to get
me well into that sweet
but where AWS lambda and pyro newirth it
if I scrape a single URL it's going to
take five seconds or something like that
with the you know there's startup
latency and stuff like that which on top
of the twenty seconds is not a big win
if I start scraping batches then I get
two big effects one is if I do this
locally on my laptop I'm constrained by
the global interpreter lock or the
number of cores on my machine or
something that constrains the number of
URLs I can simultaneously scrape or the
number of jobs I can simultaneously run
to be a number like four maybe if I'm
clever and I do it asynchronously I've
increased that number but it's going to
be an order of order of a few and maybe
even one if I use pyrin I can do
arbitrarily many at the same time I
could do 256 I can do 1024 and do
whatever I want the other big advantage
of doing web scraping on AWS it turns
out that the AWS the organization those
data centers have a slightly faster
connection to the internet than Time
Warner is able to provide me in my home
so we get this big speed-up and we the
speed up I think I went from doing this
in like thirty minutes on my own machine
and like overload my internet connection
and Netflix doesn't work all that stuff
to doing it I think it took three
minutes so it's not not gone down to
zero but it's a big big speed-up let me
show you a more substantial speed-up and
more substantial numerical calculation
this is not my work if you've got
Bradford Lynch's website you can see the
details black Scholes is a differential
equation that describes the evolution of
the price of the stock over start
instruments on the stock market and
practice famously it fails to describe
the evolution the price but solving it
305 million times they're totally
reasonable thing to want to do let's say
you wanted to prove it doesn't work so
and that's a fairly substantial
calculation each one and each one is
embarrassingly parallel these are
independent time series or in theory
they're independent time series the
speed-up Bradford Lynch got you might
not be able to see it right there 270 X
and crucially when this was all done he
had no infrastructure left he wasn't
left with some huge GPU machine under
his desk that you know he's paying
through the nose for air conditioning
for he didn't have to go and talk to
data engineers or IT to set up a spark
cluster this was all done by hitting
return from a Jupiter notebook the new
infrastructure required sprung into
existence and then ceased to be when the
job had finished
I've also seen people take this approach
to like long live data engineering tasks
things like video encoding which is
embarrassingly parallel in certain forms
like you can encode if you're using an
encoding algorithm that encodes one
frame at a time that's obviously
embarrassingly parallel and that kind of
long live job can scale up or scale down
as the amount of video you need to
encode increases or decreases
importantly and that's really cool but
the use case that interest me most is
this PI RN use case and the reason I
think Services is a particular interest
for that PI R n type use case is it's
great that we can scale it up but one of
the important things we know about data
science is we spend a lot of time like
drinking coffee and sleeping and not
running these big computations so the
ability to scale down our infrastructure
to zero and not pay for it is
particularly compelling to not have a
spark cluster sitting there burning
money while we try and figure out why
the dimensions of these arrays are
backwards or something like that there's
a big big advantage I think so finally I
want to tie together the first and last
use cases this is kind of the party
trick at the end of the talk this is
hyper parameter optimization which is
embarrassingly parallel and then
deploying a model on AWS land are using
zapper this is a good fit for both these
tools and we'll see why in a second so
here we've got some some training data
this is you know apparently I want to
tell you this between the yellow blobs
and the purple blobs based on these two
features we've got features that run
from like 0 to 10 and then from like 4
to 12 and the yellow is on the right
left and the purpose on the right and if
we wanted to train a model to do this
locally we'd scikit-learn would probably
write some code a little bit like this
so we've got a K nearest neighbors
classifier that's kind of simplest thing
you can do and it will it'll do for our
purposes no globe you can sort of
extrapolate out to more interesting size
machine learning problems and we
instantiate the classifier we fit it and
we score it and we get 83.8% which is
pretty good probably the important thing
to note here is there's a magic number
and neighbors is 5 that turns out to be
the default in scikit-learn and that's
the one I picked when I first run it but
why isn't it 4 why isn't it 6 why isn't
it 10
there's no we need to try these
possibilities that's a hyper parameter
search and the right number will depend
on our data so I could do this on my
laptop this is not a large data set or a
complicated machine learning problem but
to illustrate the point I'm gonna do
that hyper parameter search using AWS
lamda and using pi r n so remember pi
requires two things a function and some
data to map the function over so we need
to create those two things so I should
have put these two the other way around
let's look at the function first at the
bottom this is a function that trains a
model given some hyper parameters so
given one set of pieper parameters it
trains one model and returns the
classifier the trained classifier we're
going to map that function across these
eight choices of the hyper parameter
it's just some Python nonsense the
double star hyper params there's just a
to allow us to inject potentially more
more hyper parameters than just the one
so that is going to return a classifier
we could map that locally using pythons
map function but instead I'm going to
use PI R n so I map it pi r n has this
utility function we haven't seen before
which is get all results which you may
be able to guess what that does and we
get back classifiers an important thing
to note here when I previously showed
you PI rent it was giving you back very
simple objects things like just numbers
the square of 2 is 4 or it was giving
you back text like the text or a
particular abstract page on nibs what's
coming back here is a rich Python
objects with data and behavior these are
scikit-learn classifiers that have been
trained but know the parameters they
were trained with that know how to score
themselves entren trained on test data
those rich objects survive the
transition but from s3 through this
pickling and unpicking onto your client
machine which is quite impressive
engineering but having got these type of
parameters back we are able to score
them and so we can now look through the
eight possibilities and we can find well
five was pretty good it was 83.8% curacy
but we could have done slightly better
we could have had a the 84.2% accuracy
if we'd have had nearest neighbors of
seven that obviously if you've done any
machine learning is a trivial scale
hyper parameter search so I made it that
way to be clear about
what's going on with pirate and but you
can imagine easily doing more
complicated things the next thing I said
I was going to do was serve this model
and before this talk I uploaded a pickle
file containing that best model the
model with seven nearest nearest
neighbor of seven I uploaded it to s3
and this is a flask application is going
to serve predictions from this model
it's doing something really stupid here
which is mate which is necessary because
we're going to deploy it on AWS lambda
and that is each time the application
runs it downloads the model and that
probably seems quite inefficient to you
why can't we if we weren't deploying on
lambda we could keep this thing running
and only download the model once it is
stupid it is inefficient it turns out
the folks AWS has made it less stupid
than it should be by caching a lot of
this stuff I said these instances like
kind of pop into and out of existence
that's kind of a lie they keep them
around they keep them warm is the
technical term they use for it very
technical and well that means if some of
this stuff is cached and this is an
example we'll see in a second when I hit
this URL that it runs pretty quickly the
rest of the code is code to deal with
flash getting JSON in as input and that
from the URL parameters and then
scikit-learn not really expecting JSON
as its input so we've bundle some stuff
up and the API is going to give you back
the string purple blob or yellow blob so
let's see it in action this is the
training data just remind you purple was
on the left and yellow was on the right
and if I now go to the URL what you're
seeing that you can see the URL
parameters I'm using when you probably
can't they're in the location bar and
I'm using feature 1 is 3 and feature 2
is 6 there so we're on the left-hand
side of the image so we're getting
purple correctly and now if I can do
this I'm gonna change feature 1 to 9
look at that machine learning in
production so we were able to do all
that without talking to data engineering
or to IT or getting anyone's help this
is what you as a data scientist can now
do using tools like this so
right so I want to sum up finally by
saying what service is good for like
that may have seen kind of an incoherent
grab value of stuff and I want to draw
some theme so you can spot patterns in
your own work that might be a good fit
for this we saw it was good for web apps
it is able to scale up to very large
usage you know your unicorn goes well or
you don't get any users is able to do
cron jobs which are clearly you know
very sort of atomic potentially quite
short-lived tasks that most of the time
don't run and that's able to do we saw
at length embarrassingly parallel
computation using pi ret these three
things have in common that they're
bursty they potentially scale up to
quite high demands but also they
potentially scaled down to zero and as I
mentioned for me that's where serverless
shines the fact that we're not paying
for this infrastructure when we're not
using it means that we save money we
don't need to bother our friends and our
engineering and IT we can do this stuff
on our own without necessarily setting
fire to our own credit cards and
crucially we can go and have coffee and
be relaxed while we're having coffee and
not worry that the infrastructure is
running well because we've got an ec2 PT
x-large or something running that's
stressing us out so that's what it's
good for what is it not good for if you
talk to people who do like real software
engineering who do operations they'll
tell you all the things service is not
good for it's very easy to spend a lot
of money on so let's despite the fact
that I've emphasized that it's cheap in
practice because costs scale linearly
with usage at some point that for very
large use cases that graph crosses the
other graph of just buying the server so
you may want to think about that but the
use cases I'm focused on these data
science use cases there's some things
it's not good for if you're familiar
with MapReduce MapReduce is often
misused to describe algorithms that are
map shuffle reduce what that means
MapReduce is map the computation among
many workers and reduce means
consolidate the results into for example
a single number so for that squaring
example reduce debt would be either
consolidating them into a list or maybe
even taking the sum of the list the sum
of all the squares below five or
something and more commonly MapReduce in
a data engineering context involves a
shuffle
which is when the workers communicate
with each other that you can't do out of
the box with Pyron you need to like hack
it in essentially as an accurate
description of it and usually the way
it's done is by writing intermediate
results to s3 so at that point you're
having to worry about your
infrastructure a lot more than you would
if you were just using spark for example
by the same token pi Ren with its focus
on the embarrassingly parallel stuff is
not a good fit for most linear algebra
jobs where the matrices are
interestingly sized most linear algebra
complications and computations such as
matrix inversion are not embarrassingly
parallel same reason to involve in two
worth of communication you can break
them apart so they become parallelizable
and that's what libraries like desk do
that PI Ren doesn't know how to do that
it's just got this primitive map
function then PI Roman folks are working
on a library that it may not surprise
you learn is going to be called numpy
Ren which is going to know how to do
that but for now at least
don't invert a 1 million by 1 million
matrix using pirate um it's also I need
to update this slide this should say 15
minutes 900 seconds is no good for
atomic tasks that last letant longer
than 900 seconds I showed how you can
accumulate small tasks up so they're
above 20 seconds but there's no weight
if there's no way to break down your
tasks so it's below 15 minutes you're
you're stuck basically and then finally
I mentioned very briefly these machines
do not have GPUs so they're no good for
training neural networks generally even
if you could train them in under 15
minutes so I want to sum up weird by
referring back to the title of that
paper I mentioned which is a reminder
you should check out if you get the
chance it was called distributive
computing for the 99% and what I
understand that by that is if you're one
of the data science 1% what breaks a
company with a data engineering and IT
support and plant your financial support
to run long lived infrastructure then
you may not be the kind of user that the
power n team for example have in mind at
those organizations global consumption
of this infrastructure certainly varies
but it probably never goes down to 0 it
never even gets that small if they do
that they're doing a good job and they
may be operating at such a scale that
it's cheaper to just buy the cluster as
well
server lists in the sense
I present it today and the pie rent
folks are thinking I don't think is
there not the target market but who is
the target market is perhaps if you're
operating independently and you want to
do a fairly large scale computation
without dealing with spark things like
that or you want to deploy a machine
learning model in a way that can scale
up very large potentially if things go
well and then you can phone your friends
in operations and they can deploy it for
real for that use case or just for
having some fun at home taking the
square of six numbers if that's your
idea of fun
then I think Pyrenean civilus is a great
tool that's it thank you very much and
we've got five minutes
yeah hi
since pyrin works for AWS is there
anything for the other providers that is
similar that you'd suggest so the reason
why pyro n is targeted AWS is kind of a
grubby reason which is AWS gave these
folks at Berkeley free credits basically
on AWS there's nothing technical to stop
pirate and targeting other the other
server lists backends zappers are
slightly more interesting like political
story and I'm kind of reluctant against
it with a video on but my understanding
of the situation is Challis AWS is
official server list client is obviously
never going to support Google Cloud
ratio it also is missing the cron
feature that I actually used in in Zappa
the folks who build Zappa are pretty
adamant that the agnosticism of that
tool is one of its selling points and I
would agree with them in practice when I
last looked it didn't actually support
any of the other ones it was just like
we could if we wanted to we just haven't
got around to it yeah like that was a
while ago I last looked like nine months
ago in that situation may have changed
they clearly feel politically quite
strongly about them so when I said it's
not just a case of SCP in your
application between one or two of these
things that's true but the basic premise
like the in the algorithmic sense the
alternatives to AWS lambda are good fits
for pi r n I just think it's the cases
no one's done the work yet there's a
huge amount of like bookkeeping going on
in the background that wood is just not
fun code to write I think so yeah
yeah so with another potential use case
if I was a malicious actor would be to
use the distributed lambdas as
independent asks so if Google limits my
API but I write a hundred different API
keys and I want to iterate through them
through lambdas will the API ups lambda
really independently do all of those
does that warmness kind of be like Oh
Google can see it's all the same and I
could tell these are all really for
coming from the same source Google I
know Google we also see it all the same
because I got blocked by nips and the
reason is they all come from inside the
same date center so they all present
from the same subnet they all have very
similar IP addresses so any well
configured website or API is going to
figure out something's up there are
workarounds for that you know people
have written like hacky scripts not even
with the serverless in mind but we'd
like like either malicious or pragmatic
let's say web scraping in mind the
iterate not just through API keys but IP
addresses as well if you have like a lot
you know if you have you know you're in
u.s. West one and US East two or
whatever you can work around that server
list won't help you on its own with that
though is yes yeah it's yeah it's not
designed for scraping yeah and when I
was right when I was writing this talk I
made some a few mistakes right in the
scraping code and the bill at the end of
that month was not small despite what I
said in this talk I got like a thirty
dollar bill was usually it's like 30
cents and that's just me like messing up
and finding after ten minutes that I've
messed up and just paying for endless
thousand worker jobs one more question
right event if you're at a midsize
organization where let's say you don't
have you're not in that 1% you know
you're not at the point where you have
your own AWS keys yeah top tax bracket
still but not like a billionaire exactly
yeah it's like which I feel like is most
yeah how do you do accounting you know
when I request an ec2 instance like I'm
not the one who there's like an IT team
how do you guys
you're counting for them so this stuff
this is one of the challenges of like
you're trying to anticipate usage that
you can't you don't necessarily know
what it's going to be and it's a feature
an engineering feature that server lists
can scale up to arbitrary usage but
that's a feature that is going to make
accounting extremely nervous like what
if this is success that would be a
disaster on the counting's point of view
I saw there's like a communication
problem there up like you know this is a
good thing if this works out and here I
can tell you exactly what each user is
going to cost us is the per user is that
worth it the other thing to think about
is when do the lines cross like I
mentioned that what you can predict
usage exactly based on number of users
you've got because it's a linear
relationship whereas fixed
infrastructure becomes cheaper at some
point based on the number of users and
you can model when those two lines cross
and you know maybe that isn't something
you and engineer should be doing it
should mean something
the folks in finance should be thinking
about if you've got folks in finance who
who like ec2 instances yeah that's a
rough idea cool that's it thank you very
much I'm around
[Applause]